the brianna taylor case has drawn
protests nationwide and anguished calls
for justice
especially since it was announced that
no police officers would be charged in
her death
the officers who opened fire that night
are jonathan mattingly
miles cosgrove and brett hankinson now
hankinson was fired and he's been
charged with wanton endangerment
for shooting into another home where by
the way no one was injured
he has pleaded not guilty on that we
spoke with brianna taylor's boyfriend
exclusively kenneth walker about what
happened that night
along with his attorneys they have now
filed the lawsuit and are alleging a
cover-up
they explained to us why they are
accusing louisville police of trying to
flame
trying to frame rather their client
when you heard the results from the
attorney general daniel cameron the one
person who was charged it wasn't for the
death of brianna taylor
it was for firing the the shots into the
apartment next door
so how do you get away with that
there's kids in those other apartments
too
i didn't shoot them through any walls
with kids in there
but i went to jail immediately kenneth
walker was charged with
attempted murder of a police officer for
allegedly shooting sergeant john
mattingly
during the deadly police raid that
killed brianna taylor
in may those charges were dismissed
walker hired attorney stephen romines
and frederick moore to file a lawsuit
against the commonwealth of kentucky
and the city of louisville
claiming police misconduct they break
into
his house they kill his girlfriend they
frame him
for it to cover it up and then when that
cover-up falls apart
because it is so pathetic and so
inconsistent with the evidence
the case is dismissed and the charges go
away
he's supposed to say thank you
no there has to be a consequence and if
daniel cameron won't hold him
responsible
we will in the civil case fred you're a
member of the legal team but you're also
one of kenny's childhood friends he he
really does
you know build his life on protecting
others and comforting others
so it sucks to see someone you've known
their entire life hurting he was 27
years old never really been involved in
the criminal justice system at all
and all of a sudden the police say that
they announced and he decides that
you know one o'clock in the morning i
think i'm gonna decide
tonight to shoot at a cop it
just doesn't make any sense it's why
you know a dozen witnesses neighbors
all said they never heard him announce
his police
one witness well but initially he told
police in his recorded interview
they did not announce they were police
and but what's
really even more important in that
regard gail is
there are three 911
every single person says get the police
here
they're shooting guns like crazy and
kind of the same way with kenny's 9-1-1
call
nobody who calls 9-1-1 says the police
are here shooting they all
ask for the police to be sent over
louisville police targeted taylor's
apartment that night
because they had been investigating her
ex-boyfriend jamarcus glover
but walker's attorneys claim that the
louisville police
obtained a search warrant for taylor's
home under false pretenses
you have to go back to the beginning of
the warrant that they executed that
night
was obtained with perjured testimony
there's no question
that the postal inspector's office has
confirmed
that what was in the warrant is a lie
and unless
what was in the warrant that was that
brianna taylor had been receiving
suspicious packages at that address for
for mr glover that is included in the
search warrant
the postal inspector specifically
confirmed
that is not true not only did i not tell
them that i specifically told them
she had not received a suspicious
package there
what about the ballistics reports fred i
mean
kenneth said he's not sure that he shot
a police officer
they're inconclusive general cameron as
much as he
would like to say to you otherwise has
not come out and definitively proven
that the bullet that was shot by kenny
actually hit
mattingly who do you think shot officer
mattingly fred
i don't know quite frankly i'm not
convinced based on the evidence that
they have
uh that it was kenny one of the officers
says that
as the door opened bullets flew out
towards me
we know that's not true either because
he only fired the one shot because kenny
only fired one shot
so they were mistaken in their belief
and they were mistaken
in the amount of force necessary that
they needed to use
against kenny's one shot why can't we
just find the the bullet that he fired
and say oh here it is
well that's a good question because one
of the body cam videos you see
a a swat officer identify
what he says is a nine millimeter slug
on the ground
the only casings look like nine mils
however
when the crime scene unit gets to the
scene and starts documenting
it's no longer there as we've seen from
multiple body cams
that occurred after they are entering a
crime
an active crime scene that they are the
suspects in
both sides steve argues self-defense can
both be true
let's be clear kenny's right to
self-defense
is unquestioned under kentucky law you
are presumed to act in self-defense if
you are in your own home
do they have a right to self-defense
that's up for them to take to a jury
unfortunately daniel cameron says they
don't ever have to do that
in june louisville police released a
nearly blank
incident report from the night taylor
was fatally shot by officers
the report listed taylor's injuries as
none despite the fact that the 26 year
old was shot at least
five times during the deadly raid on
march 13th
what did you guys think when you saw the
incident report it's typical of the
both incompetence and corruption that is
throughout this case
okay you filed a lawsuit against the
state what do you hope to get out of
that
no amount of money can you know change
the fact that she's gone like that's all
i really care about
i just want her name to live honorable
people ask me all the time
what they can do for me i tell them say
her name
it's what you could do for me briana
taylor is her name the kentucky attorney
general's office the louisville metro
police department and the attorneys for
the three individual officers involved
declined our request for interviews or
comment you know guys yesterday i called
tamika palmer who's brianna's mother
because these stories as you might
imagine are very triggering for all of
them kenny walker had a very very rough
day yesterday
and of course it was hard for her i
caught her when she was at a
celebration of george floyd's birthday
would have been he would have been 47
yesterday
but she told me something i thought was
really interesting that night she was on
the scene because she's trying to find
out where her daughter is
brianna's emt jacket is laying there and
one of the officers picked it up and
said one of our guys left this
and she says no that's my daughter's
jacket so they said
she was an emt so they saw her name they
took out her and
it was filled with lip gloss because she
said brianna always wanted to look cute
she laughed she laughed when she said
that
so i mean even they were sort of stunned
in here that she was an emt
that's why when you see police officers
we showed yesterday
on the body cam cam say so callously
she's done
yes as they're stepping over the body it
was heartbreaking for all of them
i was very interested to hear what the
lawyers said about the warrant yes you
raised that yesterday
because i really to me this starts with
the warrant because if there if the
warrant was
falsely created essentially that's where
this really began exactly
and and you want to know what what what
that crew of police officers were told
before they went to that door you know
about about what was going on there
that's exactly right and i keep going
back to kenneth walker i woke up
thinking about him this morning because
he was in jail he couldn't go to the
funeral because he had been charged with
attempted murder so he feels
he never of the police officer he never
got a chance to say goodbye and he said
that's also part of the pain that he's
dealing with there's still so much more
to this story
we will share more of our exclusive
interview that we have with kenneth
walker
during a one-hour special on b-e-t it's
called
say her name the untold story of brianna
taylor you can watch it saturday at six
o'clock eastern
on b-e-t which by the way is a division
of viacom cbs
we'll be right back